the movie opens with a flashback to the
events that transpired on Lake Victoria
a year earlier once known as America's
spring break Capital the lake attracted
thousands of youngsters seeking Sun sand
and non-stop parties however a
horrifying twist of fate unfolded when a
long extinct species of piranha
resurfaced after 2 million years
unleashing Carnage and leaving scores of
young lives lost as the lake waters
turned Crimson with blood following the
attack a massive extermination program
was launched which destroyed the lakes's
ecosystem as a result the local economy
that depended heavily on tourism got
destroyed the year has passed since the
horrific piranha attack and the once
vibrant Lake Victoria Now lies eerily
deserted the surrounding properties
stand vacant and the once pristine Beach
is now a desolate stretch of overgrown
weeds a local news broadcast wonders the
possibility of such a tragedy occurring
again and if so where the scene shifts
to Cross Lake in Merkin County Arizona
where two farmers are on a desperate
search for their missing cow Guided by a
single SLE torch they Venture deeper
into the lake waiting through the
shallow Waters and gradually sinking
into the swampy mud after a Relentless
search they stumble upon the lifeless
body of their cow floating ominously on
the surface nearby a cluster of bright
egg like objects Bob in the water
hinting at an impending doom as the
farmers attempt to retrieve the cow
using a hook they notice its bloated
belly then what appears to be a fish egg
pops out of the dead cow unfortunately
the torch suddenly stops working and
they have to use a lighter to examine it
as a result the flame from the lighter
catches the gas emitting from the
decaying body and an explosion happens
suddenly thousands of fish eggs burst
open releasing a swarm of voracious baby
piranhas the ravenous creatures launch a
Relentless attack devouring the farmer's
legs and dragging them into the murky
depths in a desperate Act of defiance
one of the farmers grabs a piranha and
bites off its head before succumbing to
the bloodthirsty predators in the next
scene we see Chad the owner of a local
water park shooting a commercial for his
revamped establishment the ad campaign
is filled with scantily clad models and
suggestive inuendos clearly aimed at
attracting young viewers however the
filming is interrupted by the arrival of
chat's stepdaughter Maddie a marine
biology student who is spending her
holidays at the park horrified by the
objectification of women in the
commercial Maddie accuses Chad of
exploiting strippers as lifeguards
unfazed by her criticism Chad defends
his business practices claiming that he
is simply trying to make a profit as
Maddie continues to explore the Park she
stumbles upon a separate adult pool
section the area is teaming with semi
naked and fully naked women lounging by
the pool Chad's Relentless pursuit of
profit is further evident in the
presence of a condom dispenser and a
strategically placed camera that
broadcasts live footage of pool goers
emerging from the water disgusted by
this blatant display of voyerism Maddie
attempts to remove the camera but Chad
asserts his authority as the majority
owner reminding her that she has no say
in the matter later that night amidst
the dazzling fire fireworks and the
vibrant party atmosphere Mattie's
friends arrive at the water park for
their reunion Brooke who has secret
feelings for Maddie attempts to express
his longing about the Park's former
glory their conversation is abruptly
interrupted by the entrance of Mattie's
ex-boyfriend Kyle who is working a
patrol shift as a local police officer
it appears that their relationship ended
due to the challenges of a long-distance
relationship but Kyle remains eager to
rekindle their romance as a jealous
Brook silently observes Maddie informs
Kyle that her Presence at the water park
is merely temporary meanwhile Shelby and
Josh two of mti's friends are enjoying
the fireworks from a secluded spot
Shelby feeling adventurous suggests they
go skinny dipping without hesitation she
dives into the lake prompting Josh to
follow suit the couple immersed in the
Romantic Ambience indulge in intimate
moments however their intimacy is
abruptly interrupted when a small fish
darts into Shelby's private area
mistakenly believing it to be Josh's
playful touch Shelby quickly exits the
water water followed by a bewildered
Josh another couple Ashley and Travis
also seek privacy in their van away from
the fireworks Travis is still under the
influence of weed he smoked earlier
while Ashley seeks Divine forgiveness
before proceeding she seductively
handcuffs Travis to a rail however their
romantic plans go wrong when Travis
accidentally releases the handbrake
causing the van to roll into the lake
water rapidly fills the van and in the
ensuing Panic they struggle to find the
Handcuff Keys fear grips Ashley and she
escapes through a window leaving Travis
trapped inside a swarm of piranhas
descends upon Travis their razor sharp
teeth tearing into his flesh as the van
sinks deeper into the water Ashley
desperately tries to reach Travis
through the rear window but her hope is
dashed when she sees Travis's severed
arm emerged from the water a stark
reminder of the Piranha's deadly attack
Ashley's screams for help are unanswered
as the van disappears beneath the lake
surface the following day the group of
friends reconvenes at the water park
cleaning the remnants of last night's
message in preparation for the grand
opening the following day Natty inquires
about Travis and Ashley's whereabouts as
they've been absent from the cleanup
efforts however no one has seen them
suddenly Shelby throws up much to the
amusement of their friend Big Dave
meanwhile the local police department
retrieves the yellow van from the depths
of the lake Kyle watches intently as his
colleague unlocks the van but there are
no bodies inside only the handcuffs
remain fastened to the rail as a
reminder of the van's occupants Kyle
relays the news to his friends
suggesting that Ashley and Travis are
likely hiding out fearing the
repercussions of their actions Shelby
Ashley's closest confidante grows
increasingly anxious as Ashley's phone
remains unanswered overwhelmed by worry
Shelby seeks Solace at the pier dipping
her toes into the water to calm her
nerves Nattie follows closely behind
offering words of comfort to her
distraught friend sensing an easy meal
the Piranhas rise towards the pier their
razor sharp teeth bared Panic stricken
Shelby and Matty scramble to their feet
and flee towards safety the Relentless
piranhas undeterred by their escape
attempt begin to gnaw at the wooden
planks of the pier causing the structure
to crumble Shelby caught off guard by
the collapsing Pier loses her footing
and plunges into the water just as the
frenzied Piranha's close and for a kill
Matty swoops into action pulling Shelby
back to safety as Shelby scrambles to
regain her footing the pier succumbs to
the Piranha's Relentless assault
splitting into two halves Shelby finds
herself stranded on a precarious
fragment of the pier with the ravenous
fish jumping all around her encouraged
by Kelly's unwavering support Shelby
summons the courage to LEAP across with
a final surge of adrenaline both the
girls managed to land safely on the
beach Hearts still pounding in her chest
however their ordeal is far from over a
monstrous piranha emerging from the lake
and lunges towards Maddie with deadly
intent with a swift move Mattie grabs
the piranha its slimy body writhing in
her grasp together she and Shelby
unleash a barrage of rocks upon the
Relentless creature finally killing it
Barry alerted by the commotion rushes to
the scene his eyes widening in disbelief
at the sight of the Monstrous fish
recognizing the creature as a piranha a
chill of fear runs down his spine the
realization that these deadly predators
have infiltrated their peaceful Lake
casts a dark shadow over the upcoming
Water Park opening the scene shifts to
Kyle driving Maddie and Brook to meet
Carl Goodman a renowned marine biologist
residing near Lake Victoria Goodman's
groundbreaking research on the Piranhas
of Lake Victoria had catapulted him to
internet Fame when they reach his home
he is initially hesitant to engage with
the young visitors however Goodman's
reluctance goes away upon hearing
Kelly's concerns about the possible
Return of the Piranhas the reclusive
scientist Reveals His theory that the
Piranhas are navigating through a
network of underground rivers and
streams as Lake Victoria and Lake Cross
are not directly connected he showcases
a fully grown piranha specimen the
subject of his year-long study housed in
his aquarium the strength of this
piranha is astounding capable of
shattering a plate of galvanized steel
when efficiently motivated Goodman
further explains that piranhas typically
inhabit lakes with high sulfur activity
since sulfur is a byproduct of chlorine
treatment commonly used in urban Water
Systems it's plausible that the piranhas
have instinctively sought refuge in the
human water supply system this
Revelation shocks Maddie and Barry as
they realize that the water parks
drainage system empties directly into
Lake Cross if the drain pipes remain
open the Piranhas could easily
infiltrate the water park transforming
its grand opening into a bath the fate
of the water park and its unsuspecting
guests hangs in the balance as they Race
Against Time to prevent the Piranha's
invasion in a Race Against Time the
three friends hastily return to Lake
Cross under the cloak of Darkness Natty
volunteers to dive into the depths of
the lake to inspect the pipes that
connect the lake to the water park
recognizing Barry's inability to swim
Mattie embarks on the perilous Mission
alone the bars separating the pipes from
the lake water appear intact offering a
glimmer of hope Maddie begins her Ascent
toward towards the surface eager to
relay her findings however her
Tranquility is shattered when a piranha
sinks its teeth into her leg releasing a
trickle of blood into the water this
single drop summons a voracious School
of piranhas hearing a screaming Matty
Kyle promptly jumps into the water and
saves her as they lie sprawled on the
beach panting and drenched their shared
problem Sparks a rekindling of their
past romance in the next scene Kyle
pulls over chat's car for speeding
however as they Converse it becomes
clear that Kyle is accepting bribes from
chat to turn a blind eye to the water
park blatant safety violations Kyle
informs Chad that the safety grates
separating the lake from the water pipes
are holding up but he expresses concern
about the illegal well that Chad has
drilled despite his knowledge of the
safety hazards Kyle lets Chad off with a
mere speeding ticket after a long hectic
day we see Kelly finally get some much
needed rest she jumps in the bathtub and
slowly drifts in and out of sleep she
dreams of the piranha sneaking in
through the water pipe and jumping at
her the long awaited opening day for the
water park finally arrives amidst the
excitement and anticipation renowned
Baywatch actor David Hasselhoff Graces
the town with his presence residing in a
motel near the park true to his
flamboyant style Hasselhoff fills his
room with music and shares his
affections with two women on his bed
meanwhile hundreds of eager people line
up outside the water park Gates eager to
experience the thrill of the newly
revamped establishment among them is
Deputy Fallon a survivor of the tragic
Lake Victoria incident who has lost both
his legs ACC pied by his assistant
Fallon grapples with his lingering fear
of water despite his assistant's
encouragement Fallon's courage falters
and he resorts to tossing his assistant
into the swimming pool instead meanwhile
at to the raised Podium chett proudly
announces the arrival of David
Hasselhoff igniting a frenzy of
excitement among the female crowd who
flock around him for photographs
undeterred by the surrounding spectacle
Maddie remains focused on her task
diligently inspecting the park
operations behind the scenes her VIs
vigilance leads her to discover a boring
well that Chad has dug behind the park
confronting Chad Maddie expresses her
grave concern that the well could
provide a direct pathway for the
Piranhas to infiltrate the water park's
water canal system however Chad
dismisses her worries with a dismissive
wave of his hand asserting that the well
draws water from a deep underground Lake
significantly increasing his profits and
known to everyone the Piranhas find
their way into the pipes that Supply
water to the park through chat's illegal
boring well soon enough the first
piranha finds its way into the pools and
bites a kid the kid goes to his mom and
complains about a piranha bite but his
mother fed up with the talk of piranhas
dismisses him swiftly fortunately a
woman who also got put by a piranha